et guillaume canet la séparation on a
tout appris dans boîte si j'ai des
supers fiche mais le mieux pourquoi pas
on a ajourné les people et si florian
ils en sont où moi je le vois si la
semaine dernière il est seule avec son
enfant est paraît-il voilà c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment terminé alors
les premiers à avoir dégainé déjà c'est
pas voici ces publics c'était dans le
courant du mois de février où ils sont
allés les rendra publics ce qui
appartient à un public leur séparation
et c'est pas un peu plus fort parce que
moi je et c'est vrai qu effectivement
ils se sont séparés en début d'année
pour des raisons diverses et variées ça
faisait longtemps qu'il y avait de l'eau
dans le gaz on en avait parlé au moment
il y avait des rumeurs au moment de
rock'n roll au moment de la suite des
petits mouchoirs ou s'asséchait du
couple une seconde ses récents parce que
j'ai vu en aparté sur canal il ya pas
très longtemps et il était toujours avec
marion cotillard c'est lassant l'été
dernier il d'accord l'été dernier il
était au cap ferret on a qu'à voir sur
des petits bisous dans l'eau tout ça
tout allait très très bien en tout cas
sur le papier oui aujourd'hui marion
cotillard serait donc parti elle
habiterait chez une amie lui seraient
restés dans leur bel appartement
parisien de l'ouest parisien d'accord
c'est une belle histoire qui prend fin
après après près alors ça aurait fait 20
ans cette année jeu d'enfant c'était en
2002 ouai les films sur lequel ils se
rencontrent et exactement voilà il faut
dire que notre ami guillaume canet a un
petit peu la réputation d'être un
coureur c'est vrai que c'est quelque
chose qui circulaient ainsi à tenir il
aime le jogging
[Applaudissements]
encore une fois je parle au conditionnel
dans les milieux people etc où il avait
aussi la réputation d'être un couple
libre alors peut-être que ils ont
atteint leurs limites cette heure là il
ya eu 7 ya eu cette rumeur persistante
qui a duré un bon moment c'est
d'ailleurs au moment je le redis au
moment du film rock'n'roll et de lassus
des petits mouchoirs où ils ont tourné
ensemble ouais ça s'est pas très bien
passé même très mal passé entre eux à ce
moment-là à plusieurs reprises mais est
ce que parfois y'a pas des hauts et des
bas 6/1 7/6 et parfois on peut se
séparer ponctuellement parce qu'il ya
une discorde ya quelque chose qui se
passe mal on fait une pause de parfois
quelques semaines quelques mois et
finalement l'amour reprend le dessus et
on sait aussi un témoignage je ne suis
pas coutume
on a plein de l'histoire comme ça avec
des couples un peu emblématique qui
finalement se remettre ensemble i
convaincu qu'ils vont se remettre
ensemble vous avez eu des hauts des bas
vous notamment dans votre couple et des
hauts des bas tout le monde attend pas
de bas mais là de bah ça peut arriver
c'est là pour l'instant que des eaux que
des eaux ouais
ça fait quoi
[Applaudissements]
bravo mon nom et au nom mais tant mieux
tant mieux tant mieux on lit des bras
c'est connu enfin c'est connu aussi il
lui l'a beaucoup dit qu'il est très très
difficile à vivre irak terre assez
dirigiste et qu'il n'est pas très gai
dans la vie de tous les jours et dis
toujours je suis né triste je suis
quelqu'un de triste en général dans la
vie de tous les jours et c'est donc je
pense que ça doit pas être non plus là
la joie joie alors c'est vrai que vous
devez le dire parce que sur ma fille
j'ai il déclare qu déclarations
horribles j'ai ce petit troubles
cet empêchement de me réjouir et d'être
heureux je suis né triste est toujours
triste merci j'ai un double que
j'appelle mon connard à
céret ce que je dois pam était à l'arrêt
à
belmont connard dans ma vie de tous les
jours et mon entourage et ma famille
effectivement il ya un petit peu
dépressif rien ne peut pas se moquer les
pressions ces maladies oui mais voilà si
l'arrêt moi j'y crois que tellement pas
cette histoire des séparations alors
être arrivé plus ensemble chez reed
appelle ça comment
inviter c'est lui qui lui a dit vas
reprend la route des saumons moi aussi
je veux faire de même ils ont l'habitude
de tourner dans des villes dans des pays
séparé on sait ce que c'est quand on a
le même boulot et ce sont quand même des
superstars et qui plus est marion
cotillard on a encore une plus grande
que lui ll va tourner des fois à los
angeles elle va tourner partout on peut
ne pas être sous le même toit et ne pas
pour autant être séparés quand bien même
il y aurait une petite bombe il se dit
aussi qu'il a le l'échec alors la veille
l'avait rappelé aux élections ce type
est un génie attention mais l'échec de
son dernier single là un peu plongé csii
zabel et moi j'entends dire
effectivement que la complication
étaient venus aussi du fait que louis
xvi n'avait pas marché du tout et il a
même tellement particulier déjà oui et
puis elle a eu un oscar
il ajoute une chose guillaume et moi
c'est manioc
[Rires]
viens de me prendre des flâneurs de
charisme
hors marques remarquez vous yamaha
complète guillaume canet exactement
parce que j'allais parler de guillaume
canet ça va en fait lorsque je vais
fourrage il faut pour répondre à
ludivine c'est très sympa n'a pas usé
marqué
c'est très important c'est que nous en
presse people mais pas seulement nous
les infos remonte beaucoup des agences
photos qui font un travail de terrain
formidable et là je citerai pas lesquels
il ya beaucoup d' agences photo comme
kcs abaca des images qui font un travail
de terrain vague où la finale et qui
remonte des infos ouais et l'info
concernant marion cotillard et guillaume
canet a été confirmée par plusieurs
agences qui ne les ont plus vu ensemble
ils ont vu séparer d'un point de vue
géographique voilà donc c'est important
que de certains je ne dirai jamais assez
est franchement et dieu sait que je dis
pas ça pour pas être dedans puisque
personne intéresse personne pardon mais
c'est vrai mais la presse people on a
beau dire ce qu'on veut oui lèverait
vraie vraie enquête quand quelque chose
dedans voici les gens méchants feu mais
pardon anjou il est vrai même si les
paparazzi il s'affaire pour attraper aux
copains de sébastien mali là il m'a
expliqué parfois ces enquêtes l'enquète
julie gayet et hollande c'est un nom
c'est d'une enquête c'est un monde en
quête jusqu'à m'at-il dit d'abord le
cadastre de l'immeuble pour savoir où
ils peuvent sortis arriver c'est des
vrais enquêteurs franchement alors on
aime ou on n'aime pas mais il ya un vrai
professionnalisme qui a souvent pas dans
pas mal de magazines où on avec une
tasse à café on pose de matin le bonheur
affiché il ya aussi peut-être ou inondé
certains vices cachés
derrière un vice caché guillaume canet
lesquels qui ressurgit aujourd'hui entre
l'alcool
alors mettez connaissez
et encore une chose il a été aussi je
vous parle de vie s'il a été aussi il a
essayé de produire
certains des films pornographiques oh
merde
on met beaucoup de conditionnel c'est
pas méchant mais ça on arrête que là
tout d'un coup il fait du porno il al
koni fermé
[Applaudissements]
j'ai dit c'est un fait car il doit avoir
quelques vis arriver en bas mais aussi
ce petit des salles de résister aux
oublis de rien du tout en fait sur la
pédophilie c'est rien à la prostitution
et
réalisateur on produire un effort ne
sait pas dire pour autant qu'on est non
absolument un métier comme année et
c'est de l'art
de produire il a essayé de réaliser un
film pornographique hisser sur m'amuser
il ya quelques années mais aujourd'hui
peut-être qu'il a changé
et douze ans que je galère cette année
c'était mon année j'avais un début de
carrière
les femmes
étant dit des choses c'est cet angle
demande mon émission lors
son émission bon résultat pour nous il
n'est pas le colis qui sont juste
séparée sata ou che non je n'ai pas dit
que non alors il me dit avant alors est
ce que tu vas voir laurent fontaine qui
est un pro je vais dire ça si laurent me
fais
tu donnes un faux hockey surtout pas
demander alors